the feds are suing Amazon because they
say it takes too many clicks to cancel a
Prime Membership recent investigated and
here's what we found out
[Music]
it took less than 30 seconds and a total
of six clicks to cancel an Amazon Prime
membership that doesn't seem so bad but
let's put it in context the agency suing
Amazon is the Federal Trade Commission
which is responsible for Consumer
Protection so how many clicks does it
take to submit a public comment to the
FTC
as Twitter user Patrick hedger points
out that's more clicks than the FTC
complains about in their lawsuit against
Amazon and reasons Eric Bane noted that
there's no number of clicks you can make
to get rid of your FTC subscription
businesses make our lives better by
efficiently delivering affordable
products through voluntary exchange
government they take our money and waste
it so who would you rather do business
with Amazon or the government